[Musique]
le tonneau beast parisien ne peut plus
être pressé s'ils arrivent encore à
circuler il n'est plus certain de
pouvoir s'arrêter trouver une place pour
stationner est aujourd'hui un exercice
qui tient de la ronde infernale et du
jeu de hasard
cela peut demander un quart d'heure mais
aussi bien davantage
c'est devant cette situation qu'on
réagit certains esprits réaliste mettant
au goût du jour l'adage populaire un bon
tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
avec la planche certains de ses esprits
malins s'assure une place qu'ils
retrouveront noter que deux jerrycans
font aussi la faire voir une charrette
de charbonnier la peinture rouge du
stationnement interdit à un inconvénient
mieux vous l'effacer pendant le
stationnement
aussi voit-on parfois lui préférer un
autre système d'interdiction le disque
parfaitement amovible est parfaitement
illégal détail curieux dans ce domaine
l'imagination ne manque pas de
ressources
[Musique]
dernier point ça n'est pas un conseil du
préfet de police
[Musique]